Frank good evening it was a Dear John
letter that only the president could
write one that holds the promise of
reconciliation but also includes a
threat to burn your house down if you
don't behave I've decided to terminate
the plan summit in Singapore on June
12th in a morning letter to Kim jong-un
president Trump today cited anger and
open hostility in recent statements made
by North Korean officials as the reason
for scrapping the summit well many
things can happen and a great
opportunity lies ahead potentially I
believe that this is a tremendous
setback for North Korea and indeed a
setback for the world what killed the
deal was a statement from North Korea's
deputy foreign minister Cho Sun we who
said North Korea was ready for a nuclear
to nuclear showdown with the US if talks
failed Cho was reacting to a statement
from vice president Mike Pence on Monday
which she termed stupid it called pants
a political dummy as the president made
clear you know this this will only end
like the Libyan model ended if Kim
jong-un doesn't make a deal some people
saw that as a threat well I think it's
more of a fact in his letter to Kim
president Trump wrote you talk about
your nuclear capabilities but ours are
so massive and powerful that I pray to
God they will never have to be used
I've spoken to general mattis and the
Joint Chiefs of Staff and our military
is ready if necessary president Trump
again suggested today that Kim's
attitude has recently changed I think
they want to do what's right I really
think that they want to do and it was
only recently that this has been taking
place and I think I understand why it's
been taking place the president today
would not expand on what has taken place
to change North Korea's attitude but on
Tuesday he suggested Chinese President
Xi Jinping got in Kim's ear in a recent
meeting in China the second meeting I
think there was a little change in
attitude from kim jeong-hoon
so I don't like that I don't like that
president Trump described she is a
master poker player but last night the
president laid down a bed of his own
launching a national
purity investigation into car and truck
imports the move brought a sharp
reaction from China which has been
eyeing the u.s. as a rich market for its
cars drove out found a China opposes the
abuse of the term about national
security
he will seriously damage the
multilateral trade system we will firmly
safeguard our own legitimate interests
at the same time President Trump is
putting the trade squeeze on China he is
also urging Xi Jinping to keep up the
pressure on North Korea to help bring
him to the table while keeping the June
12th date may be difficult in his letter
President Trump wrote to Kim if you
change your mind having to do with this
most important summit please do not
hesitate to call me or write the
president adding I felt a wonderful
dialogue was building up between you and
me a combination of honey and vinegar to
attract the B if and when Kim jong-un's
uses to engage in constructive dialogue
and actions I am waiting it's unclear
whether North Korea was really serious
about the summit at all this past
weekend the White House sent the deputy
chief of staff our operations Jo Hagen
and an advance team to Singapore to meet
with the North Korean delegation and
nailed down the plans for the summit the
White House team waited in Singapore for
three days but the North Koreans never
showed